>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
A WEEK AGO EXACTLY, AN UNNAMED
SABOTEUR OF THE SUPREME COURT
LEAKED A DRAFT OPINION BY
JUSTICE SAM ALITO'S PLATING LIE
ROE V. WADE OUGHT TO BE
OVERTURNED.
PEOPLE WENT COMPLETELY
HYSTERICAL, BUT HIS VIEWS WERE
NOT ESPECIALLY CONTROVERSIAL.
ROE IS BAD LAW OVER THE PAST
HALF-CENTURY MANY HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT INCLUDING MANY
PRO-CHOICE DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING
JOE BIDEN.
IF YOU ARE AN OFFICE HOLDER WHO
SUPPORTS LEGAL ABORTION, THE
OBVIOUS SOLUTION IS TO VOTE FOR
LEGAL ABORTION HAD PASSED A LAW
LIKE THEY DO IN DEMOCRACIES.
IT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
THAT IS HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
DEMOCRACY IS A TIRESOME PROCESS
AND WORST OF ALL THE OUTCOME
ISN'T ALWAYS GUARANTEED.
THEY PREFER WHAT THEY CALL
DIRECT ACTION, NOT DEMOCRACY.
LIBERAL ACTIVISTS IMMEDIATELY
SET ABOUT THREATENING THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES AND
ATTACKING CHRISTIANITY.
A GROUP CALLED RUTH, IN HONOR OF
RUTH BADER GINSBURG, HOSTED THE
HOME ADDRESS OF EVERY
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE BECAUSE
THEY ARE CONSERVATIVE.
TO INVITE VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT COMMITTED GET THEM TO
CHANGE THEIR VOTES.
THEN RUTH SENT THIS TO
PRACTICING CATHOLICS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
"STUFF YOUR ROSARIES ENTER
WEAPONIZED PRAYER, WE WILL BE
BURNING THE EUCHARIST TO SHOW
HER DISGUST FOR THE ABUSED
CATHOLIC CHURCHES THAT HAVE BEEN
CONDONED FOR CENTURIES.
YOU'D THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
INTIMIDATING JUDGES BY THE WAY
IS A FEDERAL CRIME.
BUT YOU KNOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT TRY TO
STOP THIS, THEY DID NOTHING.
IN FACT, FROM HER PODIUM AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT'S
PUBLICIST ENDORSED THE COMING
HARASSMENT VERY CLEARLY.
"THE PRESIDENT'S VIEW IS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PASSION, A LOT
OF FEAR, A LOT OF SADNESS FOR
MANY, MANY PEOPLE, JEN PSAKI
EXPLAINED.
IT COULD NOT OF BEEN CLEAR.
GO FOR IT AND TERRORIZED BY THAT
IS THE WORD FROM THE LIGHTHOUSE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY DID.
THIS IS OUTSIDE
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S HOUSE.
♪ ♪
[INDISTINCT]
>> Tucker: BRETT KAVANAUGH AS
A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, A MAN,
HUSBAND, FATHER.
HE LIVES IN A NORMAL
NEIGHBORHOOD OUTSIDE OF D.C.,
DOESN'T HAVE A WALL AROUND THE
HOUSE.
MORE TO THE POINT, HIS TWO
DAUGHTERS ARE HOME.
IMAGINE WHAT IT MUST'VE BEEN
LIKE INSIDE THE HOUSE IF YOU ARE
BRETT KAVANAUGH OR HIS WIFE OR
HIS DAUGHTERS.
THE PEOPLE OUTSIDE DIDN'T CARE,
THE WOMAN WHO ORGANIZED THAT
PROTEST OUTSIDE OF HIS HOUSE
LIVES RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
APPARENTLY.
SHE IS A DEEPLY UNHAPPY
INDIVIDUAL.
BRINGING THE MOB TO HIS HOUSE
FOR A VERY SPECIFIC REASON,
BECAUSE SHE WANTS
BRETT KAVANAUGH TO CHANGE HIS
VIEWS AND SUPPORT ROE V. WADE.
SHE WAS INTIMIDATING A FEDERAL
JUDGE.
IT COULD NOT BE CLEARER.
AND YET SHE WAS NOT ARRESTED,
NOT EVEN SCHOOLED IT.
INSTEAD SHE WAS REWARDED.
SHE GOT A GLOWING PROFILE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
SO ONCE AGAIN, AND EFFECT, OUR
LEADERS IN WASHINGTON SET A VERY
CLEAR MESSAGE TO THE MOB AS THEY
DID FOR BLM.
DO WHAT YOU WANT, WE ARE IN YOUR
SIDE.
IT IS NOT LIKE YOU ARE
INSURRECTIONIST.
SO THE MOB DID.
LOOK WHAT THE MOB DID TO THIS
CHRISTIAN COUNSELING CENTER IN
WISCONSIN OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> IF THEY AREN'T SAFE, THEN YOU
AREN'T EITHER PEER THAT IS PART
OF THE MESSAGE OUTSIDE WITH
ACTION.
IT CONTINUES INSIDE THE
BUILDING.
>> THIS ISN'T AN ANSWER TO
ANYTHING.
>> WRITTEN IN DEBRIS AND GLASS
IN HER OFFICE.
THEY SAY THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
>> IT IS PRECIPITATED BY THE
LEAKED A SUPREME COURT OPINION,
RIGHT?
IT'S OBVIOUS.
>> MEDICINE POLICE SAY IT
APPEARS SOMEONE THREW A MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL INSIDE THE BUILDING.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT SAFE.
THE CHRISTIAN COUNSELING CENTER
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
OPINION.
OF COURSE, THE CHRISTIAN
COUNSELING CENTER ONLY TALKS TO
WOMEN WHO ARE PREGNANT AND ART
SURE WHAT TO DO NEXT.
THEY DON'T MAKE MONEY DOING IT,
THEY ARE NOT GETTING RICH BY
GIVING GENDER ALTERING CHEMICALS
TO YOUR KIDS OR COMMITTING
ABORTION.
THEY ARE JUST TALKING TO GIRLS
WHO ARE CONFUSED AND UPSET.
SOME OF THOSE GIRLS I WIND UP
HAVING ABORTIONS ANYWAY, BUT
THEY ARE TRYING THEIR BEST TO DO
THEIR DUTY.
NOT DOING ANYTHING AGGRESSIVE AT
ALL.
BUT BECAUSE THEIR VIEWS ARE
REPUGNANT TO THE LEFT, THEIR
BUILDING WAS FIREBOMBED.
SO HOW DID THE MEDIA COVER THIS?
HERE IS POLITICAL, WHICH IS NOT
EVEN A NEWS ORGANIZATION
ANYMORE.
HERE IS HOW THEY DESCRIBE.
A FIRE BROKE OUT SUNDAY AT THE
OFFICE OF AN ANTIABORTION GROUP
IN MADISON, WISCONSIN.
A FIRE BROKE OUT, REALLY?
THE NEWSPAPER AGREED, FIRE
BREAKS OUT OUT WISCONSIN
ANTIABORTION GROUP OFFICE.
JUST BROKE OUT.
ACCORDING TO THE POLICE CHIEF IN
MADISON WHERE IT HAPPENS, THE
ARSON IS NOT CONSIDERED A
TERRORIST INCIDENT.
SO FIREBOMBING WITH MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS FOR POLITICAL REASONS
AND THREATS ON THE WALL -- LET'S
CALL IT ACTIVISM.
SO OF COURSE, FIRES WILL
CONTINUE TO BREAK OUT IF THAT IS
YOUR POSTURE.
AND THEY ARE.
AND MORE.
HERE SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE WE
OBTAINED AN ATTACK ON THE
CHRISTIAN NONPROFIT.
THIS IS BASED IN ALEXANDRIA
VIRGINIA.
YOU CAN SEE A MAN TEARING THE
INTERCOM FROM THE WALL, EXPOSING
HIMSELF, AND A LOT MORE.
SO THIS JUST HAPPENED OVER THE
WEEKEND IN RESPONSE TO SAM
ALITO'S OPINION WITH WHICH
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN FOR AMERICA
HAD NOTHING -- THEY HAD NO ROLE
IN IT WHATSOEVER.
BECAUSE THEY ARE CHRISTIANS,
THEY WERE ATTACKED.
THE FBI HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED.
IT'S NOT JANUARY 6TH.
NO ONE STOP THE PERSON WHO DID
THAT AND NO ONE HAS STOPPED DOGS
WHO TERRORIZE SUNDAY MASSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS WAS THE SCENE OF THE SUNDAY
MASS IN LOS ANGELES.
[INDISTINCT]
>> GET OUT OF HERE.
>> AMONG OTHER THINGS, SINCERELY
RELIGIOUS PEOPLE ARE A REVILED
MINORITY AT THIS POINT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE ITS JOB TO PROTECT
UNPOPULAR MINORITY GROUPS.
THERE IS ALSO BY THE WAY FEDERAL
LAW THAT MAKES INTIMIDATING
CHURCHGOERS ILLEGAL.
FOR THE RECORD.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
NO INTEREST IN PROTECTING THIS
PARTICULAR MINORITY.
THEY ARE IGNORING THE WHOLE
THING.
THAT MEANS THAT CHURCHES NOW
NEED ARMED GUARDS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES, BUT THOSE CARDS ARE
ALSO NOW BEING TARGETED.
WATCH.
>> WE PAY YOU TO TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE.
[BLEEP] [INDISTINCT]
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
>> SEE WOULD THINK THAT CHURCHES
IN TEXAS WOULD BE SAFE AFTER
ALL, IT'S TEXAS, BUT NO,
ST. BARTHOLOMEW REPORTS THAT THE
TABERNACLE WAS STOLEN LAST
NIGHT, LIKELY IN RESPONSE TO THE
ALITO OPINION.
HERE IS SCENE OUTSIDE OF THE
BASILICA IN NEW YORK CITY.
WATCH.
[INDISTINCT]
>> I'M KILLING THE BABY.
>> Tucker: I'M KILLING THE
BABY.
COULD YOU GET AWAY WITHOUT
OUTSIDE ANY OTHER RELIGIOUS
CENTER?
ANY OTHER GROUP OF WORSHIPERS?
PROBABLY NOT.
WE WOULDN'T SUPPORT IT.
SO MAYBE YOU ARE STARTING TO
THINK THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY ABOUT
ABOUT'S BEFORE.
MAYBE IT'S ABOUT SOMETHING MUCH
DARKER THAN THAT.
TAKE A LOOK WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW IN CONGRESS.
IF YOU WANT A SENSE OF WHAT
THEIR PLANS ARE.
THIS IS A REAL PASSAGE FROM A
NEW ABORTION BILL THE DEMOCRATS
ARE TRYING TO GET THROUGH TO
CONGRESS.
"THIS ACT IS INTENDED TO PROTECT
ALL PEOPLE WITH THE CAPACITY FOR
PREGNANCY, CISGENDER WOMEN,
TRANSGENDER MEN, NONVETERINARY
INDIVIDUALS, THOSE WHO IDENTIFY
WITH THE DIFFERENT GENDER, AND
OTHERS.
SO THERE IT IS.
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT CODIFYING
ROE.
ABORTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO "NEED
THEM."
IT IS MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT.
IT IS ABOUT DISPLACING GOD AS
THE GREAT DECIDER.
DEMOCRATS NOW RESERVE THE RIGHT
TO REWRITE BIOLOGY, WHICH IS TO
SAY, DO MINYAN OVER NATURE.
NOW THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
AGAIN, THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
INTIMIDATING SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
IT IS ABOUT ATTACKING
CHRISTIANITY, BECAUSE
CHRISTIANITY STANDS IN THEIR
WAY.
MSNBC -- THIS COMES OUT.
WATCH.
>> THE CHRISTIAN RIGHT'S
DECADE-LONG PUSH TO REVOKE
ABORTION RIGHTS IS JUST PART OF
THEIR BROADER AGENDA.
WHAT ELSE DO THEY WANT?
WHAT ELSE IS AT STAKE?
>> IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ABORTION.
THIS IS ABOUT A MUCH BROADER SET
OF ISSUES THAT REALLY ARE ABOUT
A WHITE, CHRISTIAN WORLDVIEW.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S CHRISTIAN EXTREMISM
THAT IS AT THE ROOT THAT IS
ALLOWING JUSTICES LIKE THIS TO
BE CONFIRMED.
>> DISCOVERED THEY COULD
MANUFACTURE AND CHANNEL THEIR
MORAL OUTRAGE TOWARD ABORTION
CREATING A NEW TEST FOR
PRESERVATIVE DOME A
CONSERVATIVE -- SOME SANE
OUTWARD THAT THEY BELIEVE
AMERICA IS A CHRISTIAN NATION.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE MAD NOT
JUST AT ALITO, BUT AT
CHRISTIANITY AND CHRISTIANS,
BELIEVERS, PEOPLE OF FAITH.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
IT IS WEIRD IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT.
WHY ARE LIBERALS ANGRY AT
CHRISTIANITY?
CHRISTIANITY HAS BEEN THE SINGLE
GREATEST FORCE FOR HISTORY.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF HUMAN
RIGHTS, ALL OF US, IT IS
INCLUDED.
THAT IS WHERE I'M COMES FROM.
IT'S THE REASON WE DON'T HAVE
SLAVERY.
CHRISTIANS DID THAT.
IF YOU ARE SINCERE LIBERAL, IT
WOULD SEEM ODD TO HATE
CHRISTIANS.
BUT THE TOTALITARIANS ALWAYS DO
HATE CHRISTIANS BEAR THE SOVIETS
KILLED THE PRIESTS FIRST.
COMMUNISTS OBJECTED A STATUE OF
JESUS TO A SYMBOLIC EXECUTION IN
FRONT OF A FIRING SQUAD.
IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THEY DID IN WEEKS OF THE WAR
BREAKING OUT.
HERE'S THE PICTURE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
SHOOTING.
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
MODERN LIBERALS HATE
CHRISTIANITY, NOT BECAUSE IT IS
REPRESSIVE, BUT BECAUSE THEY
ARE.
ANY RELIGION THAT PUTS GOD
BEFORE GOVERNMENT IS BY
DEFINITION A THREAT TO THEIR
POWER.
MOST OFFENSIVE AT ALL,
CHRISTIANITY SPECIFICALLY
REJECTS THEIR MOST CHERISHED
DOGMA, WHICH IS RACIAL
HIERARCHY.
THE CHRISTIAN MESSAGE IS THE
OPPOSITE OF THE EQUITY AGENDA.
CHRISTIANITY DESCRIBES A
UNIVERSAL BROTHERHOOD OF MAN.
THEREFORE, FOR THAT REASON,
MORALLY EQUAL.
THAT IS GRAVELY DISEMPOWERING
FOR THE LEFT.
IF ALL PEOPLE ARE MORALLY EQUAL,
YOU CAN'T REALLY DIVIDE YOUR
POPULATION BY SKIN COLOR.
YOU CAN'T REALLY SET ONE GROUP
AGAINST ANOTHER.
YOU CAN'T TELL ONE GROUP YOU ARE
BETTER THAN THAT GROUP.
THAT IS NOT ALLOWED.
SO IN ORDER TO ALLOW IT, YOU
HAVE TO EMBRACE CHRISTIANITY.
AND THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
FOR A LONG TIME.
EVER NOTICE HOW THEY CALL A
MARTIN LUTHER KING DOCTOR, BUT
NOT REVERENT.
KING WAS NOT A PHYSICIAN, HE WAS
A CHRISTIAN PREACHER.
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO FORGET
THAT.
UNDERMINING CHRISTIANITY IS THE
CENTRAL PROJECT OF THE LEFT.
BECAUSE IT STANDS IN THEIR WAY.
DOZENS OF CHURCHES BURNED ACROSS
CANADA LAST SUMMER, THE
COUNTRY'S PRIME MINISTER REFUSED
TO CONDEMN THE FIREBALL MEANS.
HE CALLED THEM "UNDERSTANDABLE.
THE HEAD OF CANADA'S ACLU
EFFECTIVELY ENDORSED THE
FIREBOMBINGS.
BURN IT A